talk us through what's happening in
Ukraine at the moment there's been more
missile strikes today haven't they yes
more missile strikes today I mean
President Putin has made it clear that
this is Revenge for the what happened at
the Kersh straight bridge on Saturday
and yesterday there were 80 odd missile
attacks now we know about 24 drone
attacks as well so over 100 at 108
attacks yesterday another dozen or so
today and it will presumably go on the
ukrainians are reasonably successful in
shooting down some of these things or
intercepting them they seem to have
intercepted about half of all of those
things launched against them but those
attacks have come from uh in the sea
caliber missiles cruise missiles have
been fired over Moldova over moldovan
airspace the moldovans are Furious about
it
um drones that have been launched from
Belarus that have attacked different
areas attacks on Viv uh this morning and
on zapariza as well so this is a new
phase of the it's not it's not that new
we saw it in June but it's a new phase
of this part of the war that as the
Russians are doing not very well on the
Battlefront itself the the war is now
coming back to the cities and the
civilian population of Ukraine and in
terms of the West's response how would
you gauge that well the West has
condemned it
um and in a way this serves to increase
the condemnation in the west it
increases the consensus in Western
powers that they've got to bring more
pressure to Bear uh on Putin and China
and India to stop backing Putin more
practically Western Powers have said
okay we will give you more anti-aircraft
weapons the United States yeah these
sorts of things they're all all the
similar sorts of things the United
States got the nasms which is a
Norwegian American type which is a
surface-to-air missile Britain gives
them star streak which is very good
importantly Germany has this Iris T
system which it agreed to give a couple
of months ago and it's been held up in
the Chancellor's office he wouldn't sign
it off this week he said your will have
it within a few days and so there's this
sense of rushing some anti-aircraft
systems now these very sophisticated
ones that can pick out pretty well
anything missiles drones aircraft
um give them to the ukrainees they
clearly can use them pretty well and so
this is a new phase of the war before
the winter that seems now to be opening
up
and what about Belarus uh I suppose we
should go back to our map but the
talk their Belarus of course to the
north of of Ukraine uh talk of them
banding together with Russia we've
already given a lot of support haven't
they yes there are so from the very
beginning of the world president
lukashenko has has now said that that
there will be a joint Belarusian Russian
Force On the Border they'll start to
exercise
um the force is not great the Russians
haven't got many forces to offer that
because most of them are involved
already there the Belarusian armed
forces are pretty small
um in theory they've got about 50 000 in
reality they could put about 15 000
troops into the field after a while if
you had to say how many could you put
into the field this weekend it'd
probably be five or six thousand maximum
with not very good equipment it's a very
long border and so in principle if there
were an invasion of a joint Belarusian
Russian Force it could be quite close to
uh to Kiev more likely any Invasion will
be somewhere in the west
um where it's there's less to run into
one could actually you know make some
Mischief in the west but to punch
through the the border and set up a new
Frontier would require more than Belarus
and Russia could put together in the
short term but they're tempted to do it
or at least to threaten it as a way of
opening up a new front give Kiev
something else to worry about and maybe
something for which they've got to draw
troops away so far the ukrainians have
just had a reserve Force screening all
of this but they might have to do more
okay Michael thanks very much